Like, gosh, you've already produced a PowerPoint version.
I think it's already, actually, what would have been the same work? Uh, a pleasure in the back, but, okay, right, kind of, uh, okay, right, um, well, it's the kickoff leading for our project. And this is just what we're going to be doing over the next 25 minutes. So first of all, just to kind of make sure that we all know each other. I'm Laura and I'm a project manager. Great. Do you want to introduce yourself again?
I'm David and I'm supposed to be an industrial designer.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm Andrew and I'm the marketing experts.
I'm Greg and I'm he joined face.
Great. Okay. And so we're designing a new remote control. And, oh, I have to record he's here actually. So that's David, Andrew, and Greg, as much as I've done time. And yes, we've designed a new remote control. As you can see, it's supposed to be original trendy user friendly. So that's kind of our brief that we are. And so there are three different stages to the design. And I'm already sure what what you guys have already received in your emails. What did you get?
I just got the project announcement. So everybody got okay. So we're going to have
individual work and then a meeting about it and repeat that process three times and at this point you get to try out the whiteboard over there. So you get to draw your favorite animal and sum up your favorite characteristics of it. So who would like to go first? Very good. So this one here, right?
Alright, my favorite animal is like a beagle, a favorite characteristics of it, is that right? Yeah. Alright, well basically, high priority for any animal for me is that they be willing to take a lot of physical affection from their family. family and yeah they have lots of personality and be fit and then robust good health so this is blue, blue beagle, I say my name is beagle, lovely, lovely but animal would be a monkey and
the small cute and furry and when plant needs becomes real and we'll be up there with them.
You can take us along over this as you like because we haven't got an awful lot to this. What we do, we do. Don't feel like you're in a rush anyway.
Actually I told you a lot more about beagles.
I'll have to get you up again. I don't know what mine is. I'm going to have to think in the spot, man.
Impressionist. Is that a whale?
Yeah. Yeah.
Well, I'm like I don't know it's just the first animal I can think off the top of my head This big reason is because I'm allergic to most animals Fish was in that toy Yeah, and I kind of like wheels
Super sketch by the way
I was going to choose a dog as well, but I just saw a different kind of dog. My favorite animal is my own dog at home. That doesn't really look like him, actually. He looks when I can pick, actually. I see a dog in there.
Yeah.
Oh, that's very good of you.
Now I see a rooster.
What kind is it? He's a mixture of various things and what did I put him, that's just to suggest that his tail works. He's very friendly and cheery and always pleased to see you and very kind of affectionate and he's quite wee as well so you know he doesn't take up too much space and he does a funny where he chases his tail, as well. This is quite amusing.
Is he aware that this is his own tail that he's chasing?
It is. I think it is. He only does it after he's had his dinner. And all of a sudden, he's get up and start chasing his tail. He's around the living room.
Probably when he was little, he got lots of attention for doing it, and has forever been conditioned.
Maybe. Where did you find this just down here? Okay. Okay, when I need to discuss the project finance, so according to the brief, we're going to be selling this remote control for 25 euro and we're aiming to make 50 million euro. So we're going to be selling this on an international scale and we don't want it to cost adding more than 12, 50 euros, so 50% of the selling price.
Can we just go over that again? Sure. All right, so cost like production cost is 12, 50 but selling price is that wholesale or retail
like on the shelf. I don't know, I imagine that's a good question. I imagine it probably is or so actually because it's probably up to the retailer to sell it for whatever price they want but I don't know I mean do you think the fact that it's going to be sold internationally will have a bearing on highly designer at all yeah I think it will and right away I'm wondering if there's like
with DVD players, if there are zones. Oh yeah, regions and stuff. Freakancies or something?
Yeah.
Okay. As well as characters, different keypad styles and simply. Yeah.
But for a work of control, do you think that would be, I suppose it depends on how complicated our work of control is?
So this makes sense. You have more complicated characters than you, so you need more money.
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. And then the other thing international is on top of the price and thinking the price might appeal to a certain market in one region whereas in another it will be different.
Or it just like in terms of like the wealth in the country, like how much money people have this band on.
Or just like basic product positioning, the 25 euro remote control might be a big hit in London, might not be such a big hit in Greece, you know? Oh, I see.
Yeah. Marketing? Yeah. Good marketing thought. I should be writing all this time.
Right away, I'm making some kind of assumptions about what information we're given here. Making K-trendy probably means something other than just basic. Yeah. Something other than just standard. So I'm wondering right away, is selling 25 years is that sort of the, is this going to be like the premium product?
Yeah, yeah, like how much does, you know, a remote control cost? Well, 25 euro, I mean that's, that's about like 18 pounds or something, I don't know, is it as much as that? 16, 17, 18 pounds. Yeah, that's interesting. I don't know, I've never bought a remote control, so I don't know how good a remote control that would get you But yeah, it has to look kind of cool gimmicky Okay, well does anybody have anything to add to To the finance issue at all
Do we have any other background information on like how that compares to other
No actually that would be useful, wouldn't it? If you knew like what your money would get you
Yeah, interesting thing about discussing Production of remote control for me is that as you point out I just don't think remote controls being something something people consciously Assess in their purchasing habits. Yeah, it's just like Getting shoelaces with shoes or something
Five minutes to end of meeting. Oh, okay. We're a bit behind. You know what I mean like
So, like, how do you, I mean, one way looking at it would be, well, the people producing television sets, maybe they have to buy remote controls. Another way is, maybe people who have TV sets are really fed up with their remote control, and they really want a better one or something.
My parents went and bought mobile calls because they got fed up by having four or five different mobile calls. Right. Right. The panel was just, how many devices is it going to call?
Right. So in function, one of the priorities might be to combine as many uses.
Right. So do you think that should be like a man designing him before I'm able to control it? I think so. Do your satellite and your regular tally and your VCR and everything?
Maybe what we could use as an example of a successful other piece of technology is palm pilots. They're going from being just little scribble boards to cameras, MP3 players, telephones, everything, agenda. So I wonder if we might add something new to the remote control market, such as the lighting in your house.
Or even, you know, notes about what you want to watch. put in there or I want to go to such and such and that's so you can already do it, so extra functionality.
Yeah, like personally for me at home I've combined the audio video of my television set and my DVD player and my CD player. So they all work actually function together but I have different remote controls for each of them. So it's sort of ironic that they're in their, you know, the sound and everything, it's just one system, but each one's got its own little play.
OK, I'm going to have to wrap up pretty quickly in the next couple of minutes. I'll just check with nothing else. So anything else anybody wants to add about what they don't like, about remote controls they've used, what they would really like to be part of this new one at all? You keep lasing them, okay?
I'm excited that's why when you line up, it's been down the tower. Yeah.
Yeah. You get these ones where you can, if you like whistle or make really high pitched noise, they beep. There, I mean, is that something we'd want to include, you think?
I remember when the first remote control my family had was on a cable. Actually, the cable between in the TV and big like buttons that's sort of like on a blender, something like that. And you know, and I think about what they are now, it's better, but actually, It's still kind of, I don't know, a massive junky thing on the table. Maybe we could think about how it could be more streamlined.
Maybe like a touch screen or something.
Something like that. Or whatever would be technologically reasonable. It could be that functionally that doesn't make it any better, but that just the appeal of not having, these days, things of people's homes are becoming more and more chic, nicer
material and it might be worth exploring right well so it is to wrap up the next meeting is going to be in 30 minutes so that's about 10 to 12 by my watch so in between nine then as the industrial designer you're going to be working on you know that's a working design of it so you know you're doing there for user interface, technical functions, I guess that's what we've been talking about, what it'll actually do. And a marketing executive, you'll be just thinking about what it actually, what requirements it has to fulfill, and we'll get instructions emailed to you, I guess. Yes, so it's the Functional Design Steage is next, and that's the end of the music. So I've got that little message, a lot of seniors and I thought I would.
Before we wrap up, just to make sure we're on the same page here, we're given sort of an example of a coffee machine, if you're correct. So, are we right now on the assumption that our television remote control may have features which go beyond the television, or are we keeping sort of like a design commitment to television features?
Okay, well just very quickly because it's supposed to finish. No. I guess that's up to us. I mean, you probably want some kind of unique selling point of it, so, you know,
Okay. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Well, that's the end of the meeting then.
Thank you all for coming. Could I hope that was what they wanted us to do? Isn't it? Great. How do you turn this thing up? I don't know. I think if you can just leave it on maybe and then go go this is turned itself up.
Oh, there it is. Okay.
Okay. Nice.